feeling I should sing something for the
Centro but I'm not gonna sing the latest
animated offering from illumination
studios which at this point still best
known as the creators of Despicable Me
and therefore minions which means that a
lot of people probably really really
want the studio to go away don't blame
them for the memes they didn't make them
anyways this is their latest film and
honestly I think it's the best thing
they've done my opinion the despicable
Me franchise has always been kind of
it's okay I like the idea better than
the execution secret life of pets was
pretty good when it stuck to its
starting premise and it the whole
divergence with the rabbit and the group
in the sewers that didn't work so well
this this is really really quite good I
don't want to oversell it because it's
not phenomenal it's not amazing this is
not you know higher-end Pixar or Disney
or anything like that but it's really
good it's really solid and I kinda have
no major complaints about it which i
think might be a first for me with an
illumination film now just that in and
of itself kind of a nice starting place
but in case you don't know so sing
centers on a theater and I don't think
they were identified the city as Los
Angeles but it's obviously modeled on
Mars
Los Angeles so it's a struggling theater
run by a koala played by Matthew
McConaughey now he's in dire straits and
he's basically has to throw together one
more shot at a show to try and save his
theater and what he comes up with is a
singing competition and that's really
kind of it I mean there's a little more
going on behind the scenes in terms of
you know the extent he's going to to try
and keep the theater afloat and we get
insights into that and we get little
bits on all the major participants in
the competition which include a
porcupine voice by Scarlett Johansson
we've got a housewife Pig voice by Reese
Witherspoon we've got a gorilla who's
the son of a gangster I'll play by Taron
Egerton there's a little mouse with a
big voice and an even bigger ego being
played by Seth MacFarlane and a young
elephant played by Tori Kelly now here's
what really surprised me about this
there really is nothing more for me to
say about the plot without getting into
really
you know nitty-gritty details because
it's really straightforward ultimately
this is a character piece everything
just revolves around these characters
and they're all surprisingly well
rounded there's a surprising amount of
depth to all of them really many ways
they play into the sort of archetypes
that if you've ever watched a singing
competition whatever your preferred one
is you've seen these kinds of archetypes
and you kind of gravitate towards them
it's all stuff that you'll recognize you
know the homebody who has never had
their chance the one with really great
talent who's got terrible stage fright
the one who's got a huge ego and is just
kind of a jerk the one who sees this as
a way to get a better life the
singer-songwriter trying to find their
own voice all of these things you know
it's all stuff you've seen if you've
ever watched any sinking singing
competition reality show and they're all
here and but they're not just those
stereotypes either like I said they vary
they really do write out these
characters I do want to give special
mention though - Matthew McConaughey is
the Koala I actually really liked him
because the easy way to go on this being
that his goal more than anything is to
save his theatre and keep it afloat and
he's doing you know some questionable
things to keep to keep the lights on and
keep these going he's always dodging is
dead or so this is a Charlotte sand type
character this is a guy who's you know
who's he's not a step ahead of everyone
he's like a quarter step ahead ahead of
everybody everybody kind of knows that
he's Cameron pull this off but they
can't quite grab him to stop him but
what's great about that is normally
that's sort of a shyster sign kind of
skeevy kind of oh no he's just taking
advantage of everybody character here
what's motivating him is true legitimate
love for his theatre for live
entertainment he wants this to work so
bad not because he's in debt but because
he loves it and that just sort of gives
you the idea that this this is not you
know a cynical movie and it takes the
more intelligent route in terms of its
premise again I don't want to oversell
this isn't this is not brilliant but
because these characters are so well
rounded and are so well developed and
the story the film never throws the
characters under the bus for the sake of
a goofy plot twist so it did at
some points give me the fields not again
not full-on not like up and not like
inside out but it gave me feels at a
couple points and they were legit they
just weren't as intensive as something
of say a higher caliber Disney or Pixar
or Miyazaki or what-have-you but for the
studio this is coming from I actually
might start looking forward to
illumination films from here on out I
mean this is really good it's really
solid I took my daughter she had a blast
I could tell all the kids in the theater
were loving it I actually really liked
that they used pop songs that was iffy
on that like because it never feels like
the film is just a showcase for the pop
songs because they go through so many
not only our character singing them but
they're using them you know to punctuate
moments as well and so they're not
except for the final sort of act when
the show gets put on these songs don't
get lingered on you know to be like ooh
and now here's this song like that
doesn't happen so much it just keeps
going and moving forward like he and
here's this song and it's on just long
enough for you to recognize it and get
the joke or get the moment or whatever
it is and then we move on to something
else it's fast paced but it's not
hyperactive it's not like this film
would have broken into my top 10 if I'd
caught it before the end of 2016 but
this is really good it's really solid
and 2016 was a pretty decent year for
animation overall and I'll include this
on that rationale so sing have you folks
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought drop something down
in the comments and let's talk about it
don't forget to like subscribe hit that
bell so you get notifications when I put
new stuff up you can follow me on
twitter at council of geeks check out
the council of geeks podcast available
on itunes and stitcher
and as for me I will be back as soon as
I can get my next fix
[Applause]